before they get to work the children
have to register with Dona Viki who
assigns them wheelbarrows it's Saturday
6:30 in the morning in Cochabamba a city
in central Bolivia for five bolivianos a
day the children can rent a wheelbarrow
that's about 50 euro cents Denisha got
up at 3:00 a.m. to make sure she was one
of the first on the list she knows
that's the only way she'll get one of
the best wheelbarrows see a rooster
Vinicius says she likes the work she
likes carrying other people's shopping
there are 46 child workers on Dona
Vicky's list and many more across
Bolivia where child labor is a
widespread practice Dona Vicki explains
that the children have difficult family
backgrounds they often live with just
one parent or with their grandparents
and she says there's a lot of drinking
the children have to work but what's
surprising is that they also want to
NASA says that the order the goods are
loaded is very important
solid goods go underneath so as not to
squash soft things such as fruit and
heavier things go in the front of the
wheelbarrow to make it easier to push
NASA knows all the tricks she's been
working here at the Feria America market
for about five years she's one of the
oldest child workers
she says she was almost 12 when she
started at first she was scared she
would drop things or that she would
crash into something with her
wheelbarrow she was also really scared
she might lose her customer in all the
hustle and bustle as that happens a lot
the government has introduced a minimum
age of 14 but this is not easy to
enforce many child workers are much
younger
for many Bolivians child labor is
perfectly acceptable few people think
twice about hiring a child to help them
shop Quan dahveed is 11 he thinks it's
normal that children should work he says
that sometimes mothers or father's leave
the family so there isn't enough money
he explains that families are big in
Bolivia with four or five children the
customers that this market do not feel
guilty even if their own children do not
have to work this customer says she's
trying to help she says it makes sense
to help a young boy buy schoolbooks
it's compensation for the fact that he
is hired to work but of course she says
these kids should be playing just like
her children who right now or at a
painting class as he works Quan dahveed
hopes that he will be paid well if he's
lucky he'll get ten bolivianos about a
euro for 45 minutes of hard work but the
children are not always lucky and that's
why they've set up their own trade union
with their own membership cards
this is our ID says Yvonne it's to prove
that were not street kids or glue
sniffers NASA is the trade union leader
here and she's got a tough decision to
make this crisis meeting has been called
because some of the children got drunk
and beat up a nine-year-old they
violated the union rules
NASA wonders want to do with them
whether they should be thrown out
forever or for three months or for three
weeks or one month she asks what will
happen if they come back and cause
trouble again
it's decided that the children won't be
allowed to work at the market for a
month
it's a tough verdict NASA knows that the
children live in difficult conditions
and that they badly need the money just
as she does a few days later we head to
the outskirts of Cochabamba
it's one of the poorest parts of the
world this is where NASA lives and goes
to school NASA only works on the weekend
the rest of the time she focuses on her
schoolwork she's one of the best in the
class
her teacher thinks it's totally normal
that her pupils work about half the
class does she says some of them sell
clothes or fruit and vegetables or bread
other's work as shoemakers or on
building sites but she acknowledges that
some of them say they can't do their
homework because of the work so even in
a school environment people are not
necessarily against child labor after
school NASA helps her younger brothers
with her homework she spends most of her
earnings from the weekly market on
education she shows us what she has
bought with her earnings she explains
that she buys her textbooks and
notebooks herself
NASA's family had almost managed to
fight its way out of poverty when one of
her siblings had a serious accident the
hospital fees plunged them into massive
debt and they've been paying them back
for two years NASA's mother says she has
debts with three banks and that's why
the family is living as it is what can
she do she says the children are already
working even though they're still little
she finds it also painful
many families are in the same situation
for NASA whose income is crucial for the
family there is a positive side to the
work she says it has enabled her to gain
self-confidence and to make plans for
the future
dynamic quite at the trophy um he's got
a spittle she says she would like to
have her own room with her own things
and she'd like to have a big house and
wants to have nine children but no
husband if her dream comes true she says
she will also want her children to work
because she thinks it will make them
better people back in reality Gloria has
about 20 kilos in her wheelbarrow and
she earned seven bolivianos for all her
hard work that's less than one euro
Gloria says she wants to go over to
another customer near the fruit because
she will pay her a lot more money unlike
NASA Gloria doesn't have any plans for
the future and her daily life isn't the
same either
she doesn't like school and looks
forward to her work all week long oh
yeah I love the work she says I love all
kinds of work overall Gloria gets the
equivalent of about six euros that's a
decent average wage for eight hours of
child labor Gloria is well-liked at this
market she's earned a reputation for
always being in a good mood and
concentrating hard on her wheelbarrow
she tells her next customers she's
almost done and will be with her in a
moment Gloria would love to quit school
not everyone can juggle school and work
once a month child workers from all over
Cochabamba get together for a trade
union meeting this is also a time for
them to behave like children to play and
to laugh and enjoy life as well as to
talk about their demands Nexus says they
want people to respect children's rights
she explains that adults don't
understand their situation because they
never went through it themselves whereas
the children understand what it means to
work they know what's dangerous and what
isn't that's why they're getting
organized they want labor rights to be
enforced for children from the age of 12
and not 14
when they're currently planning a trip
to the capital La Paz so they can
persuade the government to listen to
their demands NASA says they're doing
politics and they can do it just like
grown-ups NASA and her fellow trade
unionists realized that many children
will have to work as long as poverty is
rampant in Bolivia but they're doing
their best to ensure that their labor is
remunerated fairly they hope that child
labor can be a dignified practice based
on rights and not exploitation